Witze.
Ich hatte mal in meiner Uni-Zeit ein Erlebnis mit einem Rollstuhlfahrer, und zwar habe ich mir da mal einen Döner geholt, einen schönen Döner. Und ich weiß nicht, wer gerade an der LMU München studiert, geht mal, gibt es glaube ich in ganz München die Kette, Olivia oder Oliva zur grüne Schrift. Besten Döner ever. Man nennt aber auch seinen Dönerladen nicht Olivia, man nennt auch seine fucking Frittenbude nicht Natascha. Ein guter Dönerladen muss für mich einen unaussprechlichen Namen haben. Wenn ich einen Dönerlein so, oh, gehen wir heute zu Harry, hieß der nicht mit, der hat keinen guten Döner, der muss so Bock du lütschelöts. So muss der Klingeln, ah, guter Döner, guter Dürim. Mein Lieblingsdöner ist immer, ändert sich jeden Monat aus steuerrechtlichen Gründen zum einen, das sind die besten Döner und die haben solche Namen, Kingdönerner, Döner-King, Döner-King, King-Kong, sowas halt, also auch nicht zu viel Kreativität, wenn man merkt, da fliegt zu viel Kreativität in den Namen, sage ich, nee, nee, mehr Kreativität in den Döner. Das stimmt, weniger im Namen. Kann ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen Kreativität von da oben haben, von dem Schild haben bitte? Und das bitte in meinem Dürum haben, Dankeschön. Willst du den kreativen Döner haben eigentlich? Nee, weil ich so angewidert habe. Ja, ich habe gerade daran an schönen Döner gedacht und daran, wie ich jetzt mein Essen umstelle und dachte mir dann, fuck. Wollen wir da gleich drauf eingehen? Gehen wir gleich noch ein. Die neue Folge von Fehlkauf, Stefan. Freut euch, gleich nach der Begrüßung. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu einer neuen Folge von der Orbiter von Gesellschaft Comedy. Wir lachen ab, wir lachen über alles,
auch über dich, wir sind das Podcast
zuvor, yeah.
Mit Stefan
Tietze
und Flo.
Auf jeden Fall hatte ich meinen Döner in der Hand. Du bist so durch die Münchner
Innenstadt gelaufen, so ein bisschen schön abgeschmeckt
und was ich gemacht habe, ich weiß nicht, ob du das machst,
ich glaube, ich bin ein sehr ritueller Esser. Freak, will ich sagen. Fettsack, wie die Leute auch gerne sagen. Aber ich habe immer den Döner geholt, schön zum Mitnehmen. Immer auch, Leute, kleiner Tipp, ich glaube, das ist ein Klassiker-Tipp. Auch wenn man vorhat, den Döner direkt zu verzehren, immer zum Mitnehmen bestellen, für die Alufolie. Okay. Für die Alufolie. Auch gut. Wir alle wissen, das Problem am Döner ist, dass der Döner zwar gut ist, aber leider auf der Straße liegt. Auf der Straße liegt. Ja, während man versucht, ihn zu essen, weil er runterfällt. Das Beruhigendste am Döner ist übrigens, dass die vor dir zubereitet werden. Das empfinde ich als so eine Befreiung, wenn man bei KFC bestellt oder so, wo man auch manchmal so einen Nagel, einen frittierten Nagel isst aus Versehen. Ich bin ganz, ganz zufrieden immer, dass es vor den Augen gemacht wird. Aber irgendwie, ich habe da so eine übertragene Nervosität der Leute, die das zubereiten. Ich würde mich wahnsinnig unwohl fühlen, wenn Leute mir dabei zugucken würden, wie ich was mache. Schnell mal vor, das gesamte Publikum, alle 400 Leute, die dich cool finden, würden dir über den Rücken schauen, während
du ein Sketch schreibst. Von Anfang bis Ende, von der ersten Sekunde,
von der Idee bis zum Schluss,
jedes Wort, jedes Satzzeichen, das du schreibst,
jetzt setzt du die Kunst eines
naja, gesellschaftskritischen,
gesellschaft auseinandernehmenden Sketches
gleich mit der Produktion eines Döners,
da würde ich jetzt mal ein großes Fragezeichen
hinterher machen.
Ich wollte nicht rappen, ich wollte intellektuell
klicken, aber es liegt auch oft sehr nah beieinander.
So, 70-30 oft, ja.
Tatsächlich, ne, Döner ist
tatsächlich, also das ist mal die Frage, wie macht man das?
Bei mir ist es ein bisschen scharf und Saziki natürlich,
sonst mit allem keine Zwiebeln an
guten Tagen, an schlechten Tagen
geht man mit Zwiebeln. Aber immer zu mitnehmen, auf jeden Fall
für die Alufolie einfach ein bisschen mehr Halt zu bekommen.
Und dann lasse ich den aber zu und laufe dann zu einer extra Stelle in München. In München war das beim Museum Brandhorst. Hey, schickt mir mal ein Bild, alle Münchner da draußen, schickt mir mal ein Bild, wie ihr mit einem Döner von Oliver auf dieser kleinen Freifläche, dieser kleinen Wiese vor dem Museum Brandhorst steht und den Döner verzehrt. Da würde ich mich sehr freuen über so ein Bildchen, über die gute alte Münchner Zeit. Ich bin ja kaum noch in München. Ich bin ja kaum noch da unterwegs, aber es war eine schöne Zeit. Und da hatte ich den Döner mal in der Handbüste hingelaufen und dann war ein Waschsalon und dann war ein Rollstuhlfahrer in dem Waschsalon drin. Ja, sehr viele Parameter, die gerade ziehen können, sehr viele Welten, die du aufmachst. Es war 14.30 Uhr und ich glaube, es war der April. Und neben dem Waschsalon beim Pferdehof, aber das ist egal. Und dann hat mich so, die Tür war offen und dann war so ein Rollstuhlfahrer innerhalb des Shops des Waschsalons, inwie so glaube ich so 20 Waschmaschinen, ich glaube drei davon sind gelaufen oder so, aber der Grossteil ist nicht gelaufen. Und der hat die Tür offen gelassen und hat so mit seiner Krüppelhand dann so, hey, hier, ich brauche Hilfe, ich brauche Hilfe. Und dann sage ich so, ja klar, was geht, Alter, was brauchst du, bin reingekommen. Und dann wollte der, dann hatte der sich in eine Sackgasse manövriert. Ja, Problem. Mit seinem Rollstuhl, das war tatsächlich ein Problem. Und er kam dann nicht mehr raus, weil er konnte, das war so ein Austin Powers Moment, so wenn du so zwischen zwei Wänden gefangen bist und du kannst nicht mehr manövrieren, dann war er so, ja, du musst dich mal anheben und so. Und ich so, kein Problem. Und neben dann den Döner
liegt mein Döner. Du hast vorher ganz anders gesprochen.
Kein Problem. Kein Problem.
Ich hab meinen Döner auf die Waschmaschine. Ich glaube,
die ist gelaufen.
Hat ein bisschen vibriert, war aber nicht schlimm,
weil der war ja noch warm und so.
Aber hat die Materialien drin
schön durchgerüttelt nochmal. Das war gut, das war gut.
Und so ein Seas-Talent draufstellen, dann wird der automatisch.
Und dann habe ich, und dann wollte ich dem so helfen, anheben, der Rollstuhl war brutal schwer, unfassbar schwer, also wirklich so aus Gold, unfassbar schwer, mit dem Typen, ich habe es nicht geschafft, den so wegzukriegen von seiner Position und dachte mir dann, ah, wir müssen erstmal die Tür aufmachen, ganz aufmachen, so über den Türpunkt hinaus, weit auf, also über 90 Grad aufmachen. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, bei Türpunkt, dass er mich verloren hat. Über 90 Grad aufmachen. Der Türpunkt ist der Punkt einer Tür, der, wenn er bis da zu dem Punkt geöffnet wird, am optimaler Breite das Einschrittvermögens der zu bedienenden Person durchmöglich macht. Kurz mal ein Plädoyer führt an die fucking Produzenten von Autotüren. Entschuldigung, wenn man die aufstösst, sollen die bitte aufbleiben. Die geht immer wieder zu. Das macht mich wahnsinnig. Was ist denn mit denen eigentlich los? Aber die haben immer so Stufen, wie so eine Treppe. Die haben Stufen und die sind für mich undurchsichtig. Total undurchsichtig. Und vor allem, die interessiert es auch nicht. Du musst die Stufe ja manuell mit ein bisschen mehr Kraftaufwand, kannst du die Stufe ändern, aber wenn du einmal doll, um direkt auf die dritte Stufe zu kommen, den Kraftaufwand betreibst, kommt die wieder zurück.
Dann denk ich mir, dann lass es sein, dann mach keine drei Stufen.
Obwohl, wenn du einparkst neben einem anderen Auto, dann machst du die Tür so weit auf, dass sie gerade so einen Zentimeter an das andere Auto rangeht und dann benutzt das Auto nochmal so, ich glaube, die Hälfte seiner PS, um die in die Tür zuiten und noch mal wirklich den Motor anzuwerfen und alles, gesamte Kraft auf die Tür zu leiten, um dann noch mal auf dem letzten Zentimeter, batz, so richtig volle Ömne, zack dagegen. Und denkst du, ja, Car2Go, scheiß drauf, das lässt sich eh nicht rekonstruieren. Ich fahre wie ein Wahnsinniger mit Car2Go und parke nicht mehr ein. Mit Car2Go. Ich lasse es in der Fussgängerzone stehen, I don't care. Das Ding ist, bei Car2Go gebe ich mir keine Liebe mehr einparken. Diese Situation, die du gerade geschildert hast, würde mir beim Car2Go nicht mehr vorkommen, weil ich nicht in engen Partlücken fahre. Hallo, das ist nicht mein Auto. Und die wollen das, andere Leute wollen das auch noch haben. Ich parke einfach auf der Fußgängerzone, auf der Treppe meinetwegen auch. Sketch-Idee, ehrliche Car2Go-Werbung. So die wirklich damit werben, was man wirklich so macht. Du kannst dich überall hinstellen, wo du willst, fahr irgendjemanden um, kann eh niemanden rekonstruieren, weil sich keiner das Autokernzeichen merkt und auch dann man nicht rekonstruieren kann. Müll, leg's einfach ins Auto rein. Der Lacher war mir nicht groß genug und ein bisschen sehr gezwungen, mein Lieber. Ein bisschen sehr gezwungen, Stefan Tietze. Ich hab nebenbei über bessere Sketche nachgedacht. Fun your day. Aber ganz kurz, was, was, also da hast du den Rollstuhlfahrer, ganz kurz, ich bin da noch, ich hänge da noch ein bisschen gedanklich. Ja. Hast du da noch ein bisschen rummanövriert, hast es nicht geschafft, ich wäre gegangen. Weil was soll passieren? Pass auf. Was soll passieren, die Geschichte ist eh unangenehm so, mit dem wird man keine Freunde mehr, ich habe eh schon mehr gemacht, als gesellschaftlich von mir verlangt ist, Ich bin übergegangen, der kann dich ja nicht verfolgen oder so. Ja, und ich glaube, er hat ja auch noch weitere Probleme. Der meinte so, der meinte so, der meinte so, ey, ich brauche Hilfe, du bin reingekommen, wollte ihm helfen, und dann meinte er, ja, ich habe mich ja einmanövriert, und ich weiß nicht, wie ich über die Stufe wieder runterkomme. Da sagte ich, Jesus Christ, das ist erstmal ein Problem. Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das Problem mit meiner Mutter lösen soll, mit der ich leider gar keinen Kontakt habe. Ich habe vergessen, wo ich wohne. Okay, okay. Eins nach dem anderen. Dann dachte ich, ich bin clever und mache die Tür ganz weit auf, damit die Tür nicht mehr im Weg ist, damit ich mehr Platz habe. Und dann mache ich die Tür auf und weiß ja, ich muss die Tür ein ganz großes Stück weit aufmachen, lege also viel Kraft in die Tür und in dem Moment ziehe ich die Tür richtig fest an und schlag damit, wirklich mit voller Wucht
gegen seinen Rollstuhl
und gegen seine Hand. Gegen sein Mongofahrzeug,
sag ruhig, wie es ist. Gegen sein Mongomobil,
gegen seine Hand.
Momo. Und er hat nicht geschrien,
weil er es nicht spürt.
Und ich dachte mir,
habt ihr das jetzt gemerkt oder nicht?
Seit Jahren spielt er so einen kleinen Rollstuhl, seine Hand ist in einem kleinen Rollstuhl befestigt und er hatte so einen kleinen Rollstuhl noch auf der Armrede drauf. So ein kleiner Helm auf der Hand. So ein Blindenzeichen. So ein Hello Kitty Rucksack. So ein ganz kleiner Hund, der sich auf die Hand führt. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und dann dachte ich mir so, scheiße, hat der es gemerkt? Und er hat es anscheinend nicht gemerkt, weil er gerade auf die andere Seite geguckt hat und weil er die Ecke aussieht, er hat es nicht gemerkt, er tat mir scheiße und dann so, so, ich muss dann auch weiter gehen und bin gegangen. Ihre Hand ist dreimal gebrochen, tschau, bist gegangen. Weil ich kann die Tür nicht aufmachen, weil das blockiert ja, sein Rollstuhl blockiert ja, ich kann die Tür nicht ganz aufmachen.
Da dachte ich mir, sind jetzt wieder zu viele Probleme und ich bin gegangen gegangen. Das heißt, ich war gerade in der Ethik-Vorlesung, hab über Kants kategorischen Imperativ gelernt und mit dem Döner auf dem Nachhauseweg dachte ich mir, scheiß drauf, fuck it, Mensch, der Not kalt! Fuck it, das war kein stolz Moment meines Lebens. Warum erzähl ich das überhaupt, dass ich jetzt nicht erzählen müssen? Leute, ihr habt es vielleicht schon gemerkt. Das war natürlich ironisch und gelönt. Drei Folgen nach der großen Episode Behinderte geht es weiter mit unseren großen Los Wojos bei Podcast UFO. Wir nehmen mal die Gesetze auseinander. Los Mongos. Los Mongos. Arriba! Rollstuhle. Naja, also du warst heute bei dem Magazin, wo ein Gast war, im Rollstuhl saß und hast eben schon gesagt, wunderbarer Mensch, gar nicht so natürlich, Anschlag war schön fest. Man fragt sich auch immer, ja wir gucken mal, ob das Schnittmassaker überlebt, aber mal gucken. Neulich war für den Dreh gab es hier einen Rollstuhl, der elektrisch war. Mega geil! Der
war, der konnte damit rum rumfahren, der war richtig, richtig schnell und dann bin ich mit voll Karacho gegen so eine Wand gefahren, einfach so, weil ich nicht mehr richtig lenken konnte und dann konnte ein Kollege mich aus der Wand, die war so halb eingedrückt, wollte mich rausholen, ging aber nicht, weil er viel zu schwer war. Aber es ist nicht uncool, weil die müssen doch auch noch eine gewisse Fahrbarkeit haben. Aber dieser Rollstuhl war einfach nur so ein fetter Thron, der einfach so, der hat auch schon diese I don't give a fuck Masse. Also der gewinnt auch gegen Kinderwagen. Kinderwagen fliegt meidenweit durch die Luft, wenn der den trifft. Der kann machen, was er will, Du kannst auch durch Autos durchfahren. Der war so schwer, so eine Masse, unbeschreiblich. Warum? Ja, ich glaube, es ist wirklich so eine Scheiss drauf-Attitude. Da muss ja wirklich ein krasser Motor drauf sein. Ich glaube, da ist auch so eine Hebebühne mit drin, dass er so drei Meter in die Höhe gehoben werden kann und dann so wie bei so einem Kettenkarussell daran auch so rumschwingen kann. Und so einen großen Boxhandschuh, der morgen vorne manchmal rauskommt. Und Leute so backboxen. Ich stehe im Weg. Scheiß drauf. Ich freue mich auf die Zeit, wenn das kommt. Vor allem, ich denke mir mal so, Busfahren ist ja mega, geht ja nicht mit einem Rollstuhl. Es sei denn, du hängst dich hinten an dem Bus dran. Oh, clever. Ich meine, gut, der Auspuff gibt dir einfach nochmal vier Rauchvergiftungen mit, aber scheiß drauf. Das ist dann auch egal. Scheiß drauf. Dann kriegt deine Lunge auch noch einen Rollstuhl. Nee, vor allem, das ist ja toll, das Demütigste. Da musst du fragen, ob die hinten aus der hinteren Tür diese Bühne runterlassen. Die kommt dann so langsam runtergefahren. Oder? Ich glaube, nee. Der Busfahrer muss dann aussteigen vorne, muss ein betont nett sein, weil wir kümmern uns ja um die Behinderten, und nimmt dann diese Bühne und bildet so eine Rampe. Und dann müssen aber alle warten, alle sind genervt, alle müssen zum Job und du kannst aber sagen, Entschuldigung, können Sie mir diese Bühne runtermachen? Aber der Rollstuhlfahrer macht auf der Rampe noch einen schönen 360, alle applaudieren und der Tag ist gerettet. Woo! Rolli. Was ist ein Skater eigentlich? Nee, nee, nee, nie. Wollte ich mal gerne sein, ich hatte einen Cityroller, das war der Höhepunkt. Das und meine ersten Vans waren die Höhepunkte meiner Skater-Karriere. Aber ich hab nie einen Olli. Ich hab's nicht über einen Olli geschafft. Kleiner Funfact über mich, ich war der erste Mensch, der einen City-Roller hatte. Na, das ist einfach... Doch, ich war der erste Mensch. Tatsächlich, ich war der erste Mensch, ist kein Scheiß. Zu meiner Kommunion, kann man sich jetzt rekonstruieren, wann das war, ich hab zu meiner Kommunion einen City-Roller bekommen und ich bin durch München damit gefahren und ich war der einzige Mensch der Welt, der diesen Cityroller hatte. Weil du weißt nicht, dass es eine japanische Urtradition ist, dass es halt mit dem Go-Spielen hat man auch angefangen, Cityroller zu fahren und das haben schon die alten, die Perser sind schon auf Cityrollern in den Krieg gefahren. Das ist eine alte Tradition. Ich glaube, da verwechselst du dich. Ne, tatsächlich. Und danach kam natürlich der große Hype. Und dann war bei uns der Freundeskreis, also wo andere schon lange sich um Mädchen gekümmert hatten, war bei uns der große Kampf Kickboard gegen Miniroller, gegen Cityroller. Und da würde ich ja mal ganz definitiv sagen Cityroller. Cityroller ist definitiv cooler als Kickboard. Und wir waren damals so frech. Ja, aber auch weil wir beide nicht wussten, wie man den Kickroller lenkt. Keine Ahnung, dieser Knäuel. Wir waren damals aber auch so frech, wir haben gar nicht Kickboard gesagt, wir haben Kackboard gesagt. Oh, wie lustig ist das denn? Und ich weiß noch, ich hatte bei meinem Elternhaus, habe ich über der Garage, der Autogarage ist nochmal dieser, ich glaube es heisst Giebel, also dieses Dreieck, diese grosse Pyramide über dem Haus, wo das Dach drin ist.
Und da war dann so eine Luke drin und da habe ich mir dann so mein eigenes kleines Haus gebaut mit so einer Leiter, die man so rausziehen konnte, ziemlich abgefahren.
Und da war ich drin und dann, wenn meine Freunde immer rein wollten, dann mussten die das Losungswort sagen, weil klar, natürlich musst du ein Losungswort haben, das ist ja mega cool, hatten die Goonies auch.
Und das Losungswort, das kann ich jetzt verraten, also nur für alle, die dann vielleicht noch mal mein kleines Häusern wollen, das Losungswort war Kack-Roll. Kack-Roll. Schau mal, du wärst definitiv nicht in meinen Club gekommen, einfach gar nicht. Kack-Roller, äh, City-Roller, City, cool, City's cool, na, Scheiß, ach, ich muss auch, ich muss nach Hause, kann meine Mutter mich nach Hause bringen? Ja, das waren meine Kinder. Ich war der erste Mensch der Welt, der Bayblade hatte. Und zwar hatte ich nämlich dann, ich hatte so ein Geschenk bekommen, damals, auch glaube ich so bei der Kommunion oder sowas. Ey, Kommunion, wie geil war das denn eigentlich? Mega, Geld aus dem Nichts. Mein Nachbar. Ich musste viel dafür tun, die ganzen Fischgeschichten von Christus, Jesus Christus. Und man musste sich untenrum berühren lassen, aber da hat man dann auch irgendwann gefallen. Das war nicht schön. Und mein Nachbar hat zur Kommunion einen Baum bekommen. So einen kleinen Baum in einem Blumentorf, da denkst du ja, lame. Aber nee, anstatt dass da irgendwie Zitronen dranhängen, hing da Geld dran. Geld! Geldbaum! An so kleinen Schnürchen hing am Baum Geld. Und ich dachte mir so, scheiß auf den Baum, nimm das Geld. Aber es war richtig viel Geld. Nimm du den Baum, ich nehme das Geld. Und wir hauen dir ab. Und er so, ich habe einen Baum, ja, aber das Geld. Aber einen Baum. Ich glaube, das hat er auch verstanden. Ich glaube, rückblickend warst du. Aber mal ganz kurz, Baum ist schon ganz schön cool. Ein Baum ist kein dummes Geschenk, ein Baum. Ja, doch, schon ziemlich dumm. Vor allem, wenn ich einen Baumgeschenk bekommen würde, so einen kleinen Baum, ich würde ihn nicht in meinem Garten pflanzen oder so, ich würde ihn im Stadtpark pflanzen. Nee, ich würde ihn im Garten meines Nachbarn pflanzen. Oh, und dann die Pfirsiche, die drüber wachsen, nehmen. Ja genau. Und der muss sich um die Blätter kümmern, der Versager. Boah, scheiß Nachbar, ich habe noch nie Probleme mit dem Nachbarn. Aber Baybläts sind ganz geil, und dann war das so eine Holzkonstruktion mit so einem Tau, so einem Tau-Seil dran und dann konntest du das Schnur, glaube ich. Ja, Schnur. Und dann konntest du das werfen und musst dann die Schnur ziehen und dann fingen die an zu drehen und das war mein Grossteil meiner Kindheit habe ich dieses Ding gedreht, auch nicht gegen andere, einfach auf der Straße stand ich mit diesem Ding. Unten so eine Metallspitze, ganz, ganz strange. Wir waren ja so cool. Meine Kindheit ist verworren. Es gab irgendwie immer mal so Punkte, wo ich richtig Geld rausgeballert hab, wo ich so gesagt hab, so Pokémon-Karten will ich alle haben, irgendwie Lego und dann später Warhammer und so, das hab ich alles gekauft, aber dann gab's so gewisse Dinge, wo man sich dann von der Masse abheben wollte und dann gab's auch den Bayblade-Hype, ich glaub in der Parallelklasse, die scheiße B-Klasse. Ich war dann der B. Nee, immer A. B, oh, die A. Die A wie Assis, sag ich immer. Ich war tatsächlich... Ja, B wie Blödköpfe. Aber ich war tatsächlich von 1 A bis 11, 10, 11 A immer A. Ich war immer B. Exakt das Gleiche bei mir, nur mit B. Ewige Ernstfeil. Ich habe nicht einmal die Klasse gewechselt. Ich war immer in der B. 1 B bis, das war es 9 B. Immer A. Krass. Und da war es so, dass in der Parallelklasse waren Bayblades und wir haben gesagt, so näher haben wir keinen Bock drauf, weil es zu teuer und ist ja Quatsch. Und dann haben wir uns selber Bayblades gebaut aus Lego-Technik. Und das ist gar nicht so dumm. Oh, wie furchtbar. Das ist cool. Das ist cool. Nein, du nimmst so einen schwarzen. Ich höre den Physiklehrer beeindrucken, dass man mit Fischertechnik plötzlich was baut. Ja, wir sind kreativ und wir malen uns unsere eigenen Yu-Gi-Oh-Karten. Ja, fuck you! Das ist, das wirst du nicht mehr zu retten, weil da kannst du gleich notgeschlachtet werden, wenn du dir deine eigenen Yu-Gi-Oh-Karten malst. Nee, schön diese schwarze Kantenstäbchen und das grösste Zahnrad, glaube ich, hat die da vor Augen, das grösste Legotechnik-Zahnrad, wo auch so Löcher drin waren und da kannst du dann so Stacheln dran machen. Das ist super Bailbail. Cool. Und da kann man dann tatsächlich auch gegeneinander kämpfen und dann natürlich so adaptieren, so mein Bailbail hat verloren, was kann ich am Design verändern und so und das war eigentlich ein cooler Kampf, es hat Spaß gemacht. Warum hat sich das noch nicht so richtig durchgesetzt? Ich kann es sein, dass ich mich irre, aber so richtig nicht. Ich glaube nämlich, Roboter, die gegeneinander kämpfen im Ring, so kleine Roboter. Wie im Fernsehen, so die sind vergesteuert. Wie gut ist das denn, wenn Roboter gegeneinander auf den Tod kämpfen? Das finde ich so cool, aber es ist nicht so richtig ein Thing. Aber wenn es Teams gegeneinander gibt, die Roboter bauen, die gegeneinander kämpfen, so ein Advanced Beyblade. Also wirklich Advanced. Aber das ist doch total geil. Die sind einfach so Kampfmaschinen. Die haben auch teilweise einfach so eine Flex, die einfach zwischendurch angeht. Ja, das war sehr gut. Aber habe ich mal gesehen, es gibt einen Trend in Japan, dass sie dieses Konzept nehmen, so diese Kampfroboter gegeneinander kämpfen. Und es mit Menschen machen. Und es parodieren. Und zwar machen die so möglichst hilflose Roboter. Oh, auch geil. So möglichst unbeholfene, dumme, die dann halt so, keine Ahnung, dann hat jemand so eine Schaufel. Toaster gegen Thermomix! Dann hat jemand so eine Schaufel, die er so nach oben heben kann, könnte potenziell Leute umwerfen, aber die Schaufel geht nach unten, so dass es sich immer so selber nach oben drückt, was gar nichts bringt. Wollen wir das noch machen mit guter Arbeit? Einfach mal Haushaltsgeräte gegeneinander kämpfen lassen? Aber dann müssen wir halt gucken, was es da gibt. Aber so ein Mixer gegen einen Toaster? Aber wie kommen die in Kontakt? Wie kommen die in Kontakt? Das ist die Frage. Weil die Längen halt nebeneinander, ne? Die müssen sich aufeinander zubewegen, oder? Ja, aber da muss man, wenn man das knacken kann. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man einen Mixer in einen Mixer wirft? Geht der kap kaputt oder entsteht ein schwarzes Loch? Instant Dimensionsriss. Keinen Spaß, keinen Vorspann, kein Intro, straight Dimensionsriss. Straight Dimensionsriss, straight andere Dimensionen, wo es dann keine Mixer gibt. Das kann sein, ey, das ist ja geil. Mixer in Mixer. Was passiert dann, wenn man Toaster toastet? Ist auch eine gute Frage. Oder was ich mir aber dachte, wie krass es wäre, wenn du wenn man Toaster toastet?
Das ist auch eine gute Frage.
Oder was ich mir aber dachte, wie krass es wäre, wenn du so einen Toaster nimmst und auf den anderen Toaster draufstülpst,
so dass wenn der Toaster fertig ist und nach oben springt, in den oberen Toaster reingeht, nochmal getoastet wird,
dann verbrannt ist, wieder runterspringt und dann immer so hin und her geht, weil es ist ein Perpidum mobile.
Am Rand gab es so eine Stufe, wo du einfach, wenn es dir zu lasch war, kannst du es einfach ein bisschen mehr einstellen. Ey, wir hatten, meine Elternhausen hatten Toaster, das war ein Ding, ey, der hat ja auch mal irgendjemand für so vier PS zu viel reingebaut einfach. Da sind die Toaster immer rausgehandelt. Otto Motor, so ein Wum Wum Wum Wum Wum Wum Wum.Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-Wum-W Bin dann weggegangen und hat dann irgendwie W.O.W. gezockt oder Mayonnaise gegessen oder sowas. Und dann ist der rausgekommen und dann ist oft einer, einer war weg. Ich hab zwei Toaster reingetan und ich kam zurück und einer war raus. Und dann dachte ich mir, gut, das ist halt mein Beitrag an den Toastergott einfach so. Das ist halt der Toastergoblin, der muss halt auch befrieden werden. Und irgendwann hat meine Mutter mal diese Küchenzeile, auf denen es stand, so sauber gemacht und hintergerückt und stellt sich raus, Tausende Toast, eine Toastlandschaft, eigene Kulturen, wir haben angefangen, irgendwie Weihnachten zu feiern. Ja, aber in den Zwischenraum, zwischen dieser Küchenzeile und der Wand, sind die Toaster reingefallen. Hä, was ist das für ein Toaster? Und dann waren da wirklich bestimmt 20 Toaster und so. Du warst so dumm, es war ein Einschlusstoaster, du hast da hinten noch eins zwischen Wand und Toaster reingeschoben. Komischerweise hat meine Mutter auch direkt gewusst, dass ich es war. Die ist nie aufgefallen, dass ein Toast fehlt. Und ich dachte, ja, ich dachte, da hat nur ein Toast rein. Die dachten, das wäre ein schwarzes Loch. Ja, ich dachte, es ist der Tribut an den Toastgott. Bei mir ist es kontinuierlich zu wenig PS in Dingen, habe ich das Gefühl. Vor allem in dir selbst. Am Wochenende war ich beim Friseur und dann gibt es ja, ich habe eine Frisur, wo man rasieren muss, wo man halt auch so einen Rasierer hat und dann nimmt die Friseure einen Kamm. Richtig seitlich oder was? Ja, hinten auch. So nimmt die einen Kamm und dann rasiert die darüber weg. Und dann der erste Rasierer wurde angesetzt, dachte mir, ja, ist der coolste Part, der macht am meisten Spaß. Dann freust du dich den ganzen Monat drauf. Endlich mit dem Rasierer. Sie kommt mit dem Rasierer wurde angesetzt, dachte mir, ja, ist der coolste Part, der macht am meisten Spaß. Ach dann, freust du dich den ganzen Monat drauf.
Endlich mit der Rasierer, sie kommt mit dem Rasierer an und macht den an und dann kommt zu folgendem Geräusch und er geht aus in meinen Haaren, was massiv wehtut, weil dann diese Scheren stecken bleiben und das Ausreissen, die sagt, okay, sorry, ich nehme einen anderen Rasierer. Der andere Rasierer macht den an, also mega viel viel zu leise schon für den Rasierer, weil so ein Riesending geht auch aus, und das war dreimal, war es der Fall, dass der Rasierer an meinem Kopf einfach ausgegangen ist. Ja. Das ist, glaube ich, das beschreibt mein Leben ganz gut. So wie bei dir, dass der Toaster vielleicht ein bisschen zu krass ist, der Toaster bei mir. Das stimmt, bei mir ist es vielleicht zu krass einfach. Ja, ich glaube, wir reichen uns da ganz gut aus. Das, was bei dir zu viel ist, ist bei mir zu wenig. Das habe ich immer erzählt, aber es ist eines der lustigsten Erlebnisse meiner Kindheit. Da wollte ein Freund von mir, wollte mal Roulette spielen und hat sich so ein Casino-Brettspiel gekauft, wo da war dann Roulette drin und Billard und alles und so, so kleine Ausfassung und hat auch so eine Roulettscheibe. Und dann war es Plastik auf Plastik, es hat nicht so gut funktioniert, deswegen hat er sie geölt. Das Drehding. Genau, deswegen hat er es geölt und dann hat er so angefangen zu drehen und es hat sich brutal schnell gerichtet, es hat nicht mehr aufgehört einfach so. Und wir saßen da irgendwie und haben uns irgendwie unsere T-Shirts schwarz angemalt, so frackmässig, wollten cool im Casino sein und dieses dreht sich, wird immer schneller und hebt ab, preutzig. Aber er hat eure T-Shirts, ganz kurz, er hat eure T-Shirts schwarz angemalt. Es war Casino-Nacht bei uns in der Siedlung. Mein Gott, hat er immer auf, auf die demütigsten Punkte der Geschichte zu konzentrieren. Und irgendwann dachte er sich, scheiß drauf, und hat ein Lineal so reingesteckt. Und hat es dann so wie so ein Lineal in die Speichen von einem Fahrrad, so in dieses Roulette-Ding, so um es anzuhalten. Aber das finde ich ein geiles Sketch. So ein Casinotisch, wo das gedreht wird und dann hört es einfach nicht auf, das beim Roulette zu drehen. Aber in dem richtigen Casino dreht sich das ja durchgehend, das hört ja nicht auf. Doch. Nein, doch. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Klar, das ist Sinn. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Du schnippst die Kugel rein und die Kugel findet dann ihren Platz, aber das ganze Rad dreht sich weiter und dann nimmt man die Kugel aus dem drehenden Rad und schnippt die wieder rein. Das Rad selber hört nicht auf, zu drehen. Das kann sein, dass es ab und zu mal wieder ein bisschen angewimmelt wird, damit es nicht aufhört, aber an sich hört das nie auf sich zu drehen. War wieder der Beweis, dass Recherche jeden Drive aus jedem Gag nimmt. Es war weniger Recherche, sondern Wissen. Grundwissen. Deine Fakten. Du und deine Scheiß-Drecks-Fakten. Hast du mal Bock auf Casino irgendwie? Du bist jetzt 21 bald. Ja. Hättest du Bock mal? Ja, ich war schon mal im Casino, ich war in Las Vegas und da habe ich mal, obwohl ich viel zu jung war, gespielt. Und dann hat man, es gibt viele Fotos von diesem Urlaub und auch speziell von diesem Abend, wo die rückblickend komisch aussehen, weil ich bin halt so ein 14-jähriger Junge, der schon sehr gross war, ungesund gross und deswegen wurde ich wahrscheinlich nicht ertappt und wurde nicht sofort weggenommen von den Slot-Machines.
Und dann saß ich da und am Anfang sieht man noch so, yeah, Vegas, mit so einem Mickey-Mouse-Shirt, geil, alles klar.
Und dann gibt es halt diese Bilderstrecke von diesem Abend, wo ich im Casino war und immer frustrierter werde,
irgendwann auch so anfangen, so Drinks in der Hand zu haben.
Und dann plötzlich so immer, immer zusammengesackter vor so einer Slot-Maschine sitze und irgendwann auch so gefühlt so eine Zigarette im Mund, so Augenringe, so Vegas, alles, was wie Vegas ein Leben kaputt machen kann, als wenn man einem Abend geschafft. Ich glaube, es könnte man gut auch, dass man immer so deinen Cash einblendet, wie viel du hast. Mein Downfall. Gehst du rein, so 100 Dollar und dann so 80 Dollar, 70 minus 20, minus 80, minus 400, nein.
Wie so ein Film, wo man so über Jahre lang ein Leben zerfallen sieht, war an diesem einen Abend halt einfach am Anfang noch geil, geil und dann immer, immer zusammengesagt, davor dieser Slot beschienen. Ich habe, Kasino finde ich ganz cool. Ich würde immer gerne pokern in einem Kasino. Ich glaube, da wirst du komplett abgezogen. Kann gut sein, aber ich würde es gerne mal probieren. Ich glaube, alle Leute, die Profis an den Poker spielen, die versuchen gar nicht so zu spielen, dass sie andere Profis schlagen können, sondern die wollen Stefan Titzer aussaugen. Ja, genau. Die legen sich einen Spielstil zu, mit dem man bestenfalls mit den Profis überhaupt nicht stösst, kollidiert, sondern nur die Trottel ausnimmt. Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch sehr einfach, weil die immer die gleichen Fehler machen, weil es einfach ein Spiel ist. Das versteht man ja irgendwann. Ich glaube, in Monopoly würde ich auch irgendwann gewinnen, wenn man das häufiger spielt und so ein paar Kniffe kennt einfach. Das ist halt echt interessant, weil das auch so ein bisschen ein Skillspiel ist. Aber Online, Poker online war ich immer ganz gut so, oder? Also wenn es um Spielgeld geht, komischerweise, da gewinnt man dann immer was. Aber das ist auch Quatsch zu spielen, weil du kannst halt nicht spielen, weil es geht ja darum, dass du dein Geld beschützt. Und in dem Moment, wo du kein Geld hast, spielst du ja anders. Und das ist kein Spiel mehr dann. Das macht keinen Sinn. Verstehen viele nicht. Ich glaube, das versteht so ziemlich jeder. Das verstehen viele nicht. Ich habe schon mit vielen Leuten darüber gesprochen, aber da kommt einfach nur Bullshit zurück. Was mir gerade eingefallen ist, es kommt oft im Leben nur Bullshit.
Sorry. Guinness Buch der Rekorde,
glaube ich, der, der lameste
Guinness, was ist der lameste Guinness Buch der
Rekorde Eintrag?
Wo du, wo du jemandem sagt, so, ich stehe im Guinness Buch
der Rekorde, echt krass, wofür denn?
Für den lamesten Guinness Buch der Rekorde
Eintrag. Und was du dann sagst, ha ha, für den Menschen
mit den wenigsten Guinness Rekorden der Welt,
Stefan Thietze, null. Stefan Thietze und 400 andere Menschen. Ja. Mehr andere. Wesentlich mehr. 400 Millionen andere. Nee, mehr. Milliarden. Wie viel? Drei. Milliarden Menschen? Wie viele haben keinen Eintrag, meinst du? Nee, aber oft ist es ja sowas wie, grösstes Publikum bei einem Baseballspiel, 120.000. Und dann sagst du, ich stehe im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde. Nee, tust du nicht. Doch, ich war bei dem Baseballspiel. Ja, das zählt aber nicht. Die komplett imaginäre Person, die ich gerade gemimt habe, geht davon aus, dass man durch... Das ist ein ziemliches Arschloch. Ich hasse solche Leute, die man sich vorstellt, und die völlig irreal sind. Nee, wer für mich lameste Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Rekord ist, ältestes Tamagotchi. Und er war wirklich, weil ich gesagt habe, ich bin der erste Mensch mit dem City-Roller, und dann war Guinness-Buch der Rekorde so ein Kapitel Kollektionen und Sammler und so. Also generell schon mal die langweiligste, weil da ist dann so, größte Kollektion von leeren Chipstüten, 202. Ja, wow. Grösste Kollektion. Danke, Rainer Kahlmund. Ui, wir müssen auch mal ein paar popkulturelle Gags machen, wo wir die Masse mitnehmen. Und er war halt so, weil ich halt einfach zufälligerweise die erste Person der Welt war, die ein City-Roll hatte, war dieses 15-jährige Mädchen, stand halt zufälligerweise an der ersten Stelle, als der Spielzeugladen an dem Tag aufgemacht hat, an dem es zum ersten Mal Tamagotchis gab, und war so ein Foto von der, die so einen Schlabberpulli anhat, 15-jähriges Mädchen, Pferdeschwanz, stand da so, völlig unbeeindruckt mit ihrem Tamagotchi, so, und war halt dann ältester Tamagotchi, so, einfach so, I don't give a fuck, I don't care. Ich glaube, die meinen damit, was am längsten überlebt hat. Nee, einfach, das war Sammler. Das war Kategorie Sammler, einfach das älteste. Ich dachte, Tamagotchi meint das Lebewesen da drin. Und du sagst, ältestes Tamagotchi. Nee, Gerät. Und sie hat so lange gepflegt, dass es nicht gestorben ist. Nee, Gerät. Das wäre dann unter Videospiele. Ich glaube, es geht ums Gerät. Da waren dann so Kategorien wie älteste Vase der Welt, ältestes Werkzeug der Welt, bla. Tamagotchi ist seltsam. Ich habe auch so viele Tamagotchi sterben lassen einfach. Aber kann man die resetten, oder ist das Gerät dann kaputt, wenn das Tamagotchi... Ach, das ist scheiße. Oh, das wäre geil gewesen. Man müsste es so machen, dass einfach dann das Gerät kaputt ist. Das wäre so evil. Weil wenn du es resetten kannst, dann kannst du doch doch. Kinder werden traumatisiert, wenn wir Spielzeuge machen würden. Ja, aber besser aufs Elternsein vorbereiten. Können die schon hier mit achtem Kind kriegen. Ist doch super. Stimmt, ich habe auch oft bei meinem Kind den Reset-Knopf gesucht. Bei meiner Kinderleiche. Game over. So haben wir bei so einem Kindersarg. Was tun sie denn da? Ich weiß, es ist eine schwere Zeit für uns. Der Reset-Knopf. Kann man ausspielen, kriegt es selber zu. Ich meine, du kennst ja Pfannkuchen. Jeder macht mal ab und zu Pfannkuchen, macht so Teig und jeder weiß, der erste Pfannkuchen sieht richtig scheiße aus. Da ist dann zu viel Öl drin, das ganze Öl ist dann von oben. Da ist die Frage, ob der scheiße aussieht, wenn man weiß, der wird scheiße aussehen und man gibt sich extra keine Mühe. Ich glaube, es ist einfach, weil du hast noch nicht genau die richtige Menge und es ist noch zu viel Öl ist dann von oben oder so. Da ist die Frage, ob der so scheiße aussieht, wenn man weiß, der wird scheiße aussehen und man gibt sich extra keine Mühe. Nee, ich glaube, es ist einfach, weil du hast noch nicht genau die richtige Menge und es ist noch zu viel Öl und dann Bahnsteht und dann geht Öl, fließt über dem Pfannkuchen und das sieht dann scheiße aus. Da denkst du eh, komm, brat ich weg, gebe ich dem Hund kein Ding. Ich glaube, so würde ich bei meinem ersten Kind auch denken. So das erste Kind so, ich mache eh alles falsch, scheiß drauf. Das zweite Kind, Nadja, komm schon, bitte, du bist das Glück der Familie, aber das erste Kind, komm, das geht doch eh kaputt so, du kannst ja nicht alles. Das ist der erste Name, der jetzt eingefallen ist, ich finde, das ist so spannend, ich glaube, am meisten. Man soll ein unverfänglicher Name sein, damit sich niemand angesprochen fühlt, außer alle Nadjas da draußen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, am meisten verrät man über sich selber, sowas tief in die, ich finde es sehr spannend, zum Menschen durchzudringen, weil mittlerweile man macht so viele rum, so viele Hüllen und Masken. Ich glaube, die Sachen, die dir als erstes einfallen, so die ersten Namen, die du benutzt, die ersten Städte, die dir einfallen, wenn du improvisierst, ich glaube, improvisieren sagt am meisten über dich aus. Assoziieren, ja. Genau, alsoieren, genau. Also schnelles, schnelles Improvisieren, Assoziieren von Dingen.
Ja, gibt es ja auch so klassische, psychoanalytische Möglichkeiten.
Einfach, dass die gewisse Sachen, Jung hat das gemacht, dass du so Sachen sagst und dann musst du sagen, so Mutter und dann.
Okay, genau.
Also kann man sich zum Beispiel den Film Dangerous Method anschauen mit Kieran Knightley, wo die das machen und wo dann auch einmal der, ich glaube, der Puls oder so gemessen wird und dann die Zeit, wie lange jemand braucht, um zu antworten. Ob das Humbug ist, weiß ich nicht. Bist du bereit? Ich muss die Assoziation sagen. Ja. Mal gucken, was, schreibt mal in die Kommentare, was ihr glaubt, was das über Florentin aussagt. Ich bin jetzt aber nicht ehrlich, weil jetzt sage ich irgendwas Lustiges, weil ich denke, ich muss lustig sein. Nein, du musst ja schnell sein. So schnell fallen mir keine lustige Dinge ein.
Ich sage jetzt Waffel einmal, egal was du sagst. Okay, gut, dann abstrahiert
das, dass es lustig gemeint ist, aber
denkt euch bei jedem
Begriff eine lustige Antwort, lacht laut
und dann kommt die richtige.
Und denkt euch trotzdem mal, bei ihm ist die Ironie weg.
Boah, das ist schwer.
Buch. Lesen.
Ich bin ein Genie. In deinem Inneren bist du ein unkreatives Arschloch. Feuerlöscher. Feuerlöschen. Okay, in deinem Inneren bist du ein Mensch, den ich nicht kennenlernen will, mit dem will ich auch kein Gespräch mehr führen. Er ist so, wow. Was hat dein Inneres heute beigetragen? Der Therapeut verlässt das Zimmer.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, du bist so langweilig.
Fuck you!
Es geht weiter, es geht weiter.
Okay, beruhige dich ein bisschen.
Land.
Stadt.
Fluss.
Flüsschen.
Nuss.
Nüsschen.
Bus.
Busen.
Wir brechen an der Stab.
Satzzeichen.
Komma.
Fragewort.
Warum?
Wessen?
Dessen?
Hobby. Hobby. Hobbit. Charaktereigenschaft. Schwierig. Tod. Leben. Liebe. Hass. Sex. Cool. Das war das Interview mit dem zwölfjährigen Florentin. Vielen Dank für die Antworten. Wir können mal gucken.
Schreibt mal in die Kommentare, was ihr glaubt, was das jetzt ausreicht.
Ja, ich will eure vollständige Analyse.
Cool.
Aber ich glaube, du bist mit dem rein.
Puh, ja.
Das kann tatsächlich eine Menge Aussagen cool. Ja, cool. Wow, Sex Machine, Flo in den Wind. Ich fand den Nuss-Nüsschen im Moment auch Nüss-Nüsschen.
Ist ja nicht so schlecht.
Okay.
Wollen wir es andersrum machen?
Ich bin ehrlich, ich habe da keine Geheimnisse.
Ich haue einfach da draus.
Glück.
Ziel. Leben. Tod. Tarkan Baji. Glück Ziel Leben
Tod
Tarkan Baji
Fein
Das Ding ist, ich hätte primär nach einem Wort mit F gesucht, weil ich schon angefangen habe.
Russland.
Krieg.
Burg.
Ritter.
Einsamkeit.
Okay.
Zur Kenntnis, zur Kenntnis genau. Das war, ich höre das Wort zur Kenntnis. Sex, cool. Einsamkeit, okay. Ich glaube, der Test ergibt, dass wir einfach keine Persönlichkeit haben. Oh, wow. Oh, wow. Okay, geht's weiter? Ja. Teller. Waschen. Mutter. Vater. Penis. Vagina. Vagina. Penis. Feuerlöscher. Feuer. Florentin. Freund. Oh! Naja, wie viel ist da jetzt Ehrlichkeit dran, so wenn du gegenüber von mir sitzt? Dankeschön. Sie sind damit geheilt. Sie sind damit offensichtlich krank, schwer krank. Ich glaube, man kann sich auch schnell Dinge überlegen, das ist auch Quatsch. Also die müsste man so nach einer gewissen Sekundenzeit einfach auch abbrechen. Ja, aber deswegen hat Jung ja auch die Reaktionszeit gemessen. Und wenn du halt länger als halbe Sekunde nachdenkst, ist eh egal, was du danach sagst. Vielleicht hast du auch noch ein Problem. Vielleicht sind dann die spannenden Wörter, wo du nichts direkt zu sagst. Ja, natürlich. Ja, gut. Natürlich, sagt er. Also wäre das ein bekanntes Problem für ihn. Ja, aber schon spannend. Schon interessant. Schon spannend, ja. Im Legoland gab es auch das beste Spielzeug im Legoland. Allein deswegen würde ich noch mal gerne ins Legoland fahren. Ja, noch nie Legoland. Vergiss die ganzen Mini-Welten da irgendwie, Schlossene, Schwanenscheine, Lego und so und die ganzen 4D, 5D, 8D abgefuckten Dimensionsriss Achterbahn. Nee, das beste Spielzeug im ganzen Legoland war ganz einfach eine grosse Rampe, die ungefähr so bis zum Stirn geht, wenn man ein Kind ist. Und da konnte man dann so seine Lego-Autos draufstellen und dann gab es so einen kleinen Block, der so hochgeschoben wurde, sodass die Lego-Autos nicht runterfahren. Und dann konnte man dann auf den Knopf drücken, dann ist es drei, zwei, 1, dann wurde der Block runtergezogen, so dass alle Autos dann die Rampe runterfahren konnten. Und dann konnte man sehen, wessen Auto als erstes ins Ziel geht. So. Ja, cool. Und dann konntest du immer dein Auto umbauen. Dann konntest du immer gucken, ah, was bauen die anderen? Dann baust du drei Räder, vier Räder. Wie verändert sich das? Ah, da wird jetzt ein schneller gefahren, grössere Räder, schmälere Räder, kleiner, grösser, mehr Gewicht, weniger Gewicht. Rausgehen, Ausgang. Ausgehen, rausgehen, Cafeteria, Kantine, Mutter verloren, Hilfe. Und das war mega geil. Ihr habt da so viel Zeit damit verbracht, weil das so Spaß gemacht hat. Ja, das verstehe, das ist ein cooles Prinzip. Weil du gegen alle anderen Kinder halt zu, du denkst dir, scheiße. Ich mag auch dieses Gegen, mag ich ganz gerne eigentlich. Ja, richtig gut. Das Problem war, so ein Junge, mit dem ich mich angefreundet habe, dessen Trick war, einfach nur ein Rad zu nehmen. Kein Auto zu bauen, sondern nur ein Reifen. Es ist leichter, es sind aber schwerere Dinge. Und der hat immer gewonnen. Hä, aber warum? Der hat gewonnen. Reibung, also weniger Reibung wahrscheinlich, weil da kein Stuff dann ist. Kann sein. Aber so gönne ich mich nicht aus. Tendenziell würde ich eher Geschwindigkeit, Masse sagen, weil dann ist ja die, also du. Ja, aber da hast du Trägheit der Masse, dann braucht das sehr lange, bis es überhaupt losfährt. Ja, das ist auch wahr, aber du hast halt, ja, die Erdenziehungskraft wirkt halt mit, 3,81 Meter pro Sekunde, keine Ahnung, eigentlich nicht genau, ziemlich genau könnte das sein, und dann kann es ja, muss es ja, wenn es auf eine gewisse Masse wirkt, auf eine lange Strecke ist Masse bestimmt besser, ich weiß nicht, wie lange die das war, aber cool, er ist richtig cool, er hat richtig Spaß gemacht, und ich dachte immer so, der kann doch nicht gewinnen, nur mit seinem Reifen, und der hat trotzdem immer gewonnen. Also ich dachte mir, ich baue das geniale Konzept mit Luftwiderstand und dann so vorne dünn und hinten dick und tschu, aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Aber da wird mich mal die sozusagen die perfekte Lösung interessieren, wenn da so ein Ingenieursteam sich dransetzt und alle Legosteine analysiert und guckt so, was ist das perfekte Lego-Auto, mit dem man die beste Zeit schafft. Das fände ich richtig cool. Ist ja eine gute Metapher fürs Leben so, wenn man sich fragt, warum ist Leonardo DiCaprio so erfolgreich, warum war Munch so ein toller Maler, warum war Hitler so ein toller Anführer. Man kann sagen, sie haben einfach das Rat, sie sind einfach ein Rat. Sie sind einfach das Rat. Sie erfüllen einfach den Zweck. Sie sind genau dafür geschaffen. Das geht mir zu weit. Sie sind das Rat. Ich bin dabei, kann man das ganz gut belassen. Okay. Und im Legoland gibt es Pommes in der Form von Legosteinen. Da dachte ich mir, holy crap. Viele sagen jetzt unnatürlich, widerlich, Kapitalismus. Und im Legoland war der beste Tag meines Lebens, glaube ich. Da habe ich dann so Pommes bekommen und Schnitzel und dann bin ich auf dem Weg, war ich so aufgeregt wegen den Pommes-Legosteinen, dass mir das Tablett runtergefallen ist, alle Pommes kaputt, die haben sich so zusammengebaut, irgendwie zu so einem Galgen, komischerweise, und es war mega abgefahren, aber dann kam so eine Mitarbeiterin und so, ach, ist gar nicht schlimm, so hier kannst du dich nochmal neu anstellen. Ich dachte mir, ich liebe es hier. Ich dachte mir schon so, oh nein, jetzt habe ich alles kaputt gemacht, jetzt werde ich bestraft und so, nö, kein Ding mehr. Ich fahre da nochmal hin, scheiß doch auf meine Unterlassungsklage, mein Gott. 500 Meter ist eine Menge. In zwei Wochen bin ich in Orlando und da habe ich eigentlich Bock, dann in Universal Studios zu fahren. Da gibt es eine Harry Potter Welt, da gibt es eine King Kong Welt, da gibt es, was ist noch von Universal? Die bestimmt viele Sachen, coole Sachen. Was machst du denn in Orlando? Habe ich nochmal erzählt. Ich bin für Star Wars Celebration in fucking Orlando. Ja? Orlando, Florida. Was würde genau zelebrieren? USA, der neue Film. Der kommt da raus? Nee. Da kommt Presse, Leute.
Und da kommt der Regisseur und die Produzentin und so.
Und du darfst dann Fragen stellen bei so einem Panel oder was?
Ja, durchaus, unter anderem, ja.
Aber du ...
In meinem Podcast bin ich da.
Antenne Alderaan, da doch mal rein.
Neue Folge Out Now.
Wir können da vielleicht ein paar Fragen stellen.
Aber da dürfen dann alle den Finger heben und dann kommen drei ran von drei.
Ja gut, okay.
Aber ich bin massiv gross, trage mein orangenfarbenes Weste und werde penetrant Fragen stellen. Aber da dürfen dann alle den Finger heben und dann kommen drei ran von drei. Ja gut, okay, aber ich bin massiv gross, trage mein orangenfarbenes Weste und werde penetrant Fragen stellen. Ich glaube, das wird schon hin. Hat Chewbacca eigentlich eine Hose an? Klar, nein. Nee. Drunter vielleicht, unter seinem Fell vielleicht. Aber sieht man da den Dengel eigentlich? Nein, der hat so viel Fell. Und die pflanzen sich mit Gedanken fort. Ey, was auch viele bei, wo wir gerade dabei waren, was viele bei einem sagt, ich finde, ich war neulich in einer Notsituation und Leute um mich herum waren in Panik und Lass ich mir raten, dir ist dein Hut runtergefallen. War es für dich eine Notsituation? Ich war in einer Bahn und dann plötzlich sie stehen geblieben, in U-Bahn und dann war die im Tunnel stehen geblieben und es kam Rauch rein. Und Leute, eine Frau war ohnmächtig, instant, keine Ahnung, wie das möglich war, ich glaube, war das ein ganz anderes Problem. Dass es aus Filmen so gelernt hat, dass immer eine Frau immer Statist im Hintergrund, immer ohnmächtig wird. Mit dieser Hand vor der Stirn. Hat die die Hand gemacht? Nein. Warum macht man das? Ich glaube, weil man es gelernt hat, das Film. Ja, okay. Und andere Frauen fingen an zu husten, andere Männer fingen an zu husten. Und dann kam so eine Durchsage, ja, sorry, wir bleiben hier noch ein bisschen stehen. Und diese Rauchentwicklung kommt von der Bremse, der defekten Bremse des Zuges vor und so weiter. Ganz komisch so. Und dann war so ein Mädchen neben mir, das hat dann so gefragt, sollten wir den Notbetätigen, den Notknopf betätigen, den Notruf? Sollten wir, wenn nicht jetzt, wann sollte man denn dann den Notknopf betätigen? Das hat das Mädchen dich gefragt, dich gefragt und alle. Ja, alle, in die Runde gefragt. Leute, Leute! Es ist so ein bisschen wie so eine komische Situation, wie so ein Zombie-Apokalypse, wo sich so eine fremde Gruppe an Menschen trifft, die plötzlich so eine Zweckgemeinschaft gründet. Man sah dann plötzlich den einen mit der, ah, der Typ mit dem Skateboard, das Mädchen neben mir, der Typ mit den Kopfhörern. Mit den Samurai-Schwertern aufgerückt. Der eine schwarze, ach, der stirbt eben, komm. Aber wo in der Hierarchie hast du dich da angesiedelt? Ich war der coole, sich zurücklehrende Typ, der gar nichts davon mitbekommen hat, weil er die Kopfhörer aufhat. Aber du bist so der Streetsmarte, der dann so sagt, das Schloss geht nicht auf und du dann so mit deinem Zahnstocher, den du immer in den Mundwinkel hattest, das Schloss aufmachst. Ein Strohhalm. So sehe ich dich auch eigentlich. Nee, ich gebe dann immer so Sachen, die Hebelwirkung, solche Begriffe gebe ich dann immer rein. Und dann kam es dann zur Situation, dass sie mich halt gefragt hat, wann sollte man den Notruf betätigen. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich darüber nachgedacht, weil es war eine spannende Frage. Und dann habe ich ihr fast gesagt, ich habe es gedacht, wenn du diese Frage stellst, wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Wenn man die Frage stellt, sollten wir jetzt den Notruf betätigen? Ich dachte genau andersrum, sobald du die Frage stellst, dann schon. Sobald du dich fragst, soll ich jetzt... Sobald du noch darüber nachdenkst, ob man das sollte... Ja, wann denn dann, wenn du nicht mehr darüber nachdenkst, sondern in Panik wegläufst? Ja, genau, weil du panikerst. Nein, du musst doch drüber nachdenken können, damit du die Aktion koordinieren kannst. Ja, bei dir, nach deinem Logik würde überall Stau sein, alle Bahnen würden anhalten so, weil natürlich, es ist doch nichts passiert, es ist doch ein bisschen Rauch kommt rein, so ein paar Leute sind ein bisschen am Husten. Ja, wenn den Notknopf drückt, dann passiert da auch nichts. Also was ist denn da Notbremse oder was? Ja, die ist Quatsch natürlich. Ja, aber da ist so ein Knopf, so ein roter Notknopf. Ich glaube, dann hält es erst mal an, dann kommen die Rettungskräfte, dann kommt so ein, vorne raus, der Schaffner, und kommt dann hinten rein. So war es halt. Da wird so Automatismen in Gang getrieben. Ich frage mich sowieso oft, wann man die Notbremse ziehen soll. Weil ich denke mir, womit ich immer rechne, das Kopfkirche, das bei mir abspielt, ist vor allem Amoklauf. So, wenn ich im ICE-Lauf Amoklauf, so was würde ich machen? Tipp, ich würde mich über den Stühlen in der Gepäckablage hinter Gepäck verstecken. Tipp, seid immer die, die den Amoklauf ausüben. Richtig. Ja, hab immer mehr Waffen als der Amokläufer dabei. Sei der Amokläufer. Aber dann denke ich mir, das Dümmste, was man in der Situation machen kann, ist die Notbremse ziehen, weil das ist ja die einzige Nothandlung, die man als Passagier
tätigen kann. Aber das ist ja mega dumm,
weil dann die Bundespolizei halt irgendwann
die Gleise entlang sprinten muss, um dann
zu dem Zug zu kommen oder die SEK oder was auch immer,
was dann da eingreift. Das ist doch viel besser, wenn
der in den Bahnhof einfährt und
da die Polizei direkt zugreifen kann.
Oder die Krankenwagen und so, da müssen die alle durch die
Pumper laufen, das ist doch mega bescheuert.
Aber du siehst ja, vielleicht wenn jemand vor die Gleise fällt und dann so, hey ihr da drin, Notbremse, bitte was, wenn jemand vor die Gleise fällt, aber dann sieht es doch auch der Schaffner als erstes und fährt gar nicht erst los, der hat doch, ist doch mein Theorie, dass die so einen Alarm haben, wenn die sehen, da liegt was auf den Gleisen oder so. Da liegt auch so ein Alarm.
Gestern ist auch so ein Mann, ein Trottelmann, einfach so auf die Gleise gelaufen und dann war da so eine Strassenbahn, die hat den fast umgefahren einfach, weil er das nicht gesehen hat, weil er auch Kopfhörer im Ohr hatte. Und dann hat die Bahn halt diese eine Hupe, ich nenne es mal Hupe, aber die ist nicht hupenwürdig für so ein großes, mächtiges Gefährt, dass nämlich dieses Klingeln, wo man sich dachte, naja, wir geben Strassenbein keine Hupe, wir geben denen dieses Klingeln, weil das früher in den 50er Jahren so war. In den 1850er Jahren hatten die diese Klingel, die jemand der Hand betätigt hat, geben wir denen jetzt immer noch, obwohl die mittlerweile 80 Milliarden PS haben. Und dann kommt dieses Geräusch und der Mann hat uns natürlich nicht vom Ort bewegt. So bei dem Geräusch denkst du, da winkst du noch freundlich. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist so demütigend. Man müsste echt so ein, ja, so eine Tonaufnahme von so einem Kind, so, wie sowas. So ein Typ, der ruft, hey, hau ab, du Otto, sieh da, bleb. Vor allem, das finde ich immer mega lustig. Ich habe letztens wieder eine Schlagzeile gelesen, da dachte ich mir, Potsblitz. Und zwar hieß es irgendwie sowas wie, ja, Gesetzesgericht hier irgendwo in Stockholm hat entschieden, dass Elektroautos Geräusche machen müssen. Also die sind ja langsamer als leiser, Motoren, Benzinmotoren, Autos und machen wenige Geräusche. Und deswegen ist es gefährlich, weil du siehst sie nicht und dann wirst du umgefahren. Und deswegen müssen sie Geräusche machen. Und ich denke mir, das ist so ein wichtiger Moment in der Geschichte der Menschheit, wo man überlegt, welche Geräusche die machen. Weil jetzt wirklich noch in Millionen Jahren jahren dieses gesetz gilt halt jetzt erstmal stockholm hat einfach zu sagen und haben dieses ja auch für das gesetz für dieses geräusch schon ausgesprochen das weiß ich eben nicht und ich glaube nämlich nicht und ich würde jetzt einfach wirklich jetzt können wir entscheiden in hundert jahren wird man sich so fragen warum klingen die eigentlich so ja weil damals stefan tietze das und das und sich überlegt hat jetzt haben wir die möglichkeit ein für allemal das das Motorengeräusch von der jetzt wäre mein großer Vorschlag Musik. Und zwar einfach, dass die Musik, die innen drin läuft, wird nach außen lauter transportiert. Wenn man beschleunigt, wird es lauter auf den Autobahnen. Das ist ein Höllenlärm, weil 80 Liter einfach gerade über die A1, einfach massiver Lautstärke, groß über die Autobahn klingt. Aber ist wirklich das Letzte, was du hören willst, bevor du auf der A8 von dem Laster erfasst wirst, Bon Jovi? Ja, das ist meine grosse Frage. Was ist der letzte Song, den ich hören will? Der läuft bei mir in Dauerschleife. Ich habe überlegt, Staying Alive wäre gut. Ist ein Gag. Ist ein Gag, gib mir auch noch eine Botschaft mit, wenn ich im Sterben liege. Soll ich aufgeben oder soll ich noch leben? Und dann höre ich um die Musik, ah okay, alles klar, easy. Und es ist gleichzeitig auf die Hand schreiben, auch so, bleib am Leben. So immer, wenn du dann irgendwie blutüberströmend auf der Strasse liegst und denkst, sterben oder nicht? Ja, bleib hier im Leben. Das frage ich mich so ein bisschen. Und es ist der originale Beat für Leute, die die Herd undPutzmus-Massale betreiben. Ich wäre für das Geräusch für die Elektroautos. Ach, du meinst wie ich mir Jetpacks vorstelle. Aber auch nichts, weil das Problem an Autos ist, dass es so gleichtönig ist. Äh, aber Elektroautos kann man so, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, mi, so und so fahren die den ganzen Tag durch die Gegend. Ne, du musst ja die, ne, haben keine Gänge, ne? Mimimimimi, mimimimi, mimimimi, finde ich nervig. Re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, re, Du musst an den Dopplereffekt mitdenken natürlich.
Ja, das stimmt. Da hast du es nicht gemacht.
Wie geil das wäre.
Wir können das jetzt festlegen, wie Leute sich fühlen.
Ich glaube, ich will da noch was zu sagen.
Ich will ein Vetorecht haben für diese Entscheidung.
Oder einfach so ein Aaaaaaah!
So ein Schreien.
Aaaaaaah!
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaamatisch so. Honda, Kaschkei, Honda, Kaschkei, Honda, einfach wie so ein Pokémon. Kauft Hondas, kauft Hondas, kauft Hondas. VW Golf, VW Golf, VW Golf, VW Golf, VW Golf, VW. Daihatsu, Sonnastar! Ich glaube, es wird ja sowas wie, ich werde dich sowas von töten, wenn du jetzt da da vorbei hast, wenn da vor mir vor gelaufst. Zur Seite bitte, zur Seite bitte, bitte weg von der Straße. Guck wenigstens auf dem Zebrastreifen, wenigstens guck wenigstens nach links und rechts, guck nach links und rechts, kauf diesen Honda, ciao. Runter von der Strasse bitte, runter von der Strasse bitte, runter von der Strasse bitte. Also wir haben noch so viele offene Fragen, was das angeht. Dieses Kapitel ist für mich noch nicht abgeschlossen. Das ist spannend, das ist spannend. Und ich würde mich da auch mal ein bisschen informieren, und da würde ich nächste Woche mal ein paar Experten zurate ziehen. Aber was ich mir da, es ist ja wirklich so dieses, ja. Ich bin gerade beim Motorgeräusch, es ist kurz ein Trigger angegangen bei mir. Und zwar habe ich jemanden getroffen auf einer Party und ich habe mittlerweile das Ziel, dass ich, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, diese Gespräche bringen mir gerade nicht so viel weiter und es führt gerade nicht zu nichts, dass ich das Spannendste aus der Person herausfinden will, was ich am spannendsten finde. Das ist zumindest mein Ziel für das Gespräch, das für mich am spannendste an ihm herauszufinden oder an ihr. Und ich habe bei einer Person, ultra boring, hat auch sehr langsam gesprochen, so ein sehr langsames Gespräch, wo man direkt sagt, okay, ciao. Und diese Person hat plötzlich erzählt, dass sie für Mercedes die Bachelorarbeit schreibt, und zwar über die Motorengeräusche. Und zwar ist diese Person bei Mercedes angestellt und soll herausfinden, hat die Bachelorarbeit darüber geführt, wie das Motorengeräusch verbessert werden kann. Heißt, er baut dann so kleine Dinge ein, teilweise einfach nur so, man denkt ja, Autos sind maximal funktional, denkt man ja immer so, auch wenn man gerade in den Motorraum schaut. Aber er baut da so kleine Dinger da rein, die helfen, das Motorgeräusch zu einem angenehmeren zu machen. Indem er dann einfach so kleine Hindernisse einbaut für die Frequenzen und Schallwellen. Er ist einfach dafür da, um das maximal angenehmste Motorgeräusch zu machen. Ohne den Motor zu verändern. Ist es dann auch so ein psychologisches Ding, welche Geräusche für den Fahrer am angenehmsten sind? Es ist Audiodesign. Nur um Lautstärke. Es ist Audiodesign. Es geht darum, das Auto muss schön aussehen, also muss es auch schön klingen. Wenn man ein Mercedes kauft, kauft man auch den Klang mit. Entweder man macht es lauter oder man macht es höher, tiefer oder voluminöser. Ich finde das total geil, diese Vorstellung, dass da wirklich offenbar Leute sind, auch Audiodesigner, die daran arbeiten, dass der Klang am coolsten ist. Auch dieses Geräusch, wenn man die Autotür zumacht, hat jeder ein ganz, ganz spezifisches Geräusch vor Ohren, so kluck. Ja. Kann man gar nicht nachmachen. Kluck. Nee. So, und das, glaube ich, wird auch designt, genauso wie bei Chipsfirmen, auch so dieses Geräusch, wenn man reinbeisst, so auch so designt wird. Ich weiß nicht genau wie, aber das ist auch wichtig. Florentin Will schafft es, die Chips am Klang zu erkennen. Vier von fünf Versuchen müssen hinhauen. Kann ich dran riechen? Ryan Gosling, was sagen Sie? Kann ich dran riechen? Will er es schaffen oder will er es nicht schaffen?
Das ist Florentin Will, 19 Jahre, 14 Jahre alt, aus Ebersberg.
Oh well, I think that he... Naja, ich denke, dass er...
He looks very fat and I think he...
Er sieht ziemlich fett aus, und ich glaube...
I mean all those streams of sweat running down his T-shirt.
Naja, diese ganzen Träume.
So I think that he's very capable of being a fat gesagt? Shirts? Oder Dreams? Ganz kurz, haben Sie gerade Dreams oder Shirts gesagt? Shirts, I said Shirts. Okay, also er sagt, dass die Shirts so aussieht, als ob sie von Schweiz durchtrinkt werden. Und eigentlich, als wir bei La La Land waren, haben wir sehr viele Chips gegessen. Und es war sehr, sehr lecker. Also, thank you for the Oscar again. I think he will do it. I think he will do it. I think he will do it. Peter, he's a great guy. Peter, ich glaube, er schafft es. Ich glaube, das ist dick genug und passioniert genug, um das zu schaffen. So go ahead, I think you'll make it. Great. Los, mach das, du schaffst es schon. Also, Ryan Gosling sagt, du schaffst es.
Thank you.
Wir legen los.
Wetten, top, die Wette, das.
Und die erste Chipsorte, bitte.
Kann ich es noch mal hören, bitte?
Ja. Das ist, ich glaube, ich weiß es, das ist Funny Frisch Sour Cream Chips. Absolut richtig! Einen grossen Applaus. Wow. Okay, halt die Konzentration an. Der Probe hat auch wunderbar funktioniert. Wir kommen zu Chipsorte zwei. Ja, ich glaube, das ist ganz klar, dass Cindy Pringles Hot and Spicy. Yes, Pringles Hot and Spicy. Wow, das kann er wirklich gut. Aber gut, man sieht es ja auch ein bisschen ihm an. Die nächste Chipsorte. Bling. Jetzt habe ich mich kurz geräuspert. Kann ich es noch mal hören, bitte? Mein Magen knurrt auch ein bisschen. Auf dem Publikum bitte ganz ruhig sein, es ist ja vor der Konzentration. Und nichts vorsagen, bitte.
Pringles!
Okay, alles klar, wir machen's.
Nochmal hören.
Bling!
Puh, ha, das ist...
Das ist schwer.
Das sind Fritz Dix. Richtig, absolut richtig, wow, was wir hier erleben. Ryan Gosling steht. Ja, ich denke, es ist wirklich toll, dass er so weit ist. Ich denke, er wird es auch noch weiter schaffen und wird diese Wahl gewinnen. Ich weiß nicht, welche Wahl er meint. Anmerkung des Übersetzers.
Eins musst du noch erkennen, dann sind wir hier durch mit der ganzen Nummer.
Letzte Chipsorte für dich.
Kannst du ein bisschen näher kommen, bitte? Es sind definitiv Bake-Roll-Brotchips, aber die Sorte, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Ganz, Konzentration. Rots die Brotchips und es ist... Welche Sorte ist jetzt gefragt?
Welche Sorte?
Ist ein bisschen fruchtiger.
Es ist die
Paprika Chili.
Es ist die Paprika Chili!
Dankeschön!
Ba ba, ba, War auch eine gute Show. Ja, fandste? Ach, es gab ja sonst nichts anderes zu gucken in der Glotze.
Aber ich bin echt immer,
ich werde echt ein immer grösserer Nazi,
was so
Kosenamen angeht. Also jetzt nicht für
Personen, sondern so, wenn man so
also jetzt klar, die Klassiker sind so
Schlepptop, Lappi
für Laptop, aber auch sowas wie
Glotze, Ratzefummel,
oder so, auch wenn Leute
weinen und man sagt, Schlepptop,
Er ist ein Schuss. Schlepptop, Lappi, Flaptop so, aber auch sowas wie Glotze, Ratzefummel, oder so, auch wenn Leute weinen und man sagt, oh Gott, es ist so ein ganz unangenehmes Kribbeln. Leute, die Teflon sagen, haben es auch nicht verdient, morgens aufzuleiten. Aber das sind so die Klasse, aber auch sowas wie, wenn jemand sagt, Pippi in den Augen, ich hasse das, ich hasse wirklich, das ist ganz furchtbar. So was in der Richtung. Oh, heute hat jemand gesagt, was ich hasse, und ich wäre am liebsten gegangen, den Raum verlassen, kommentarlos, mit dieser Idee müssen wir mal schwanger gehen. Ja, das ist aber auch so ein klassischer Mediensprecher. Oh, es ist so furchtbar. Vor allem, ich weiß nicht warum, aber in meinem Kopf wird es immer wörtlich übersetzt. Also wirklich wörtlich. Ja, ich habe ein Bild vor Augen.
Ich sehe ihn mit einem dicken Bauch schwanger gehen mit der Idee und denke mir, war es das jetzt wert? Ich meine, du musst so viel über dich ergehen lassen, du musst ein Leben einschrecken für diese Idee, wenn du dir schwanger gehen willst. Finde ich nicht gut. Pipi in den Augen, das ist eklig. Ich habe mir heute gedacht, wir arbeiten ja viel visuell. Also wir schreiben ja einen Text in einem kahlen, leeren, stinkenden Raum und wir stellen uns ja konstant vor, wie das dann passiert, wie die Person das spricht, wie sie dabei aussieht, in welchem Raum das ist, wie das alles aussehen muss und so. Wir stellen uns das konstant vor und erst nach Wochen sehen wir das dann tatsächlich. Das heißt, wir müssen uns sehr viel vorstellen. Deswegen dachte ich mir, oh, wir haben ja viel Vorstellungskraft. Aber dann ist mir heute aufgefallen, dass dadurch, dass wir auch Filme und Werbung und so anders sehen, uns das so einprägen und immer wieder abrufen, die Vorstellungskraft sehr stark davon geformt ist. Weil heute bin ich heimgelaufen, bin ich hierher gelaufen mit dem Gedanken Feierabend in meinem Kopf. Und dann hatte ich sofort so Bilder im Kopf, wie so ein paar Mittzwanziger-Studenten irgendwie so auf so einem Dach stehen und dann hat einer so eine grüne Glasflasche in der Hand gehabt, wo die Sonne, die gerade untergeht, so durch die Glasflasche durchscheint und dann so lauter so Wasserperlen. Ich dachte mir, geil, das ist Feuerabend. Er hat es zur Realität, er hat es weinend in seinem eigenen Sessel in kahlen Wände um ihn herum. Ja, und schaut Bojack Horseman. Und dann dachte ich mir aber so, ja, Moment mal, das ist überhaupt nicht meine eigene Vorstellung, das ist einfach nur abgerufenes Bildmaterial. Das stimmt. Das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil von Vorstellungskraft. Jemand anderes hätte einfach völlig eigene Fantasie, wohingegen wir wie immer so, ja, es ist immer so, wenn man sagt so, ja, Sketch, ja, stell dir vor, es ist so wie Arrested Development, nur mit einem High in Space. Verstanden. Weil du all diese Elemente einfach nur zusammen pflückst und sofort ein Bild im Kopf hast, weil du aber nur aus diesem Baukasten lebst, diesem Vorstellungsbaukasten, aber keine eigenen Ideen hast. Ja, aber ich glaube auch, also du spielst auch ein bisschen darauf an, dass man sagt, wie Arrested Development und das und das und dann fragt man sich, wie ist denn Arrested Development auf ihr ins Ziel gekommen und so. Aber es ist ja immer nur ein Remix und der ganzen Sachen, die es schon vorher gab. Gespannt wird es, die ersten Menschen, die dann mal überhaupt einen Stil festgelegt haben, die zu finden. Und die findet man meistens auch gar nicht, weil es die auch nicht gibt, weil die auch davor jemanden, du findest immer jemanden, der davor war. Aber auch jetzt zum Beispiel, als du erzählt hast von deiner U-Bahn, wo die Frau ohnmächtig geworden ist, ich habe mir tatsächlich dieses Rückhandaufricht. Ja, genau. Stimmt vorgestellt, so was in der Realität nie passiert. Aber jeder weiß, wenn ich Regisseur wäre und im Skript steht, Frau wird ohnmächtig, würde ich der Statistin sagen, mach das mit der Hand. So, weil das macht man so. Und was man sich auch mal vorstellt, das gehört dazu, das ist einfach Teil der Filmrealität. Wenn ich einen Sketch schreibe, wo jemand erschossen wird, will ich den wegfliegen sehen. Und dann sagst du, der Realitätsnazi neben mir sagt, nee fliegt aber nicht weg. Aber das stimmt ja, man fliegt ja nicht weg. Und Hollywood macht das aber die ganze Zeit einfach anders vor, weil es einfach spektakulärer aussieht. Die Tarantino-Morde sehen eigentlich viel schlimmer aus und viele sagen, oh, der verherrlicht Gewalt und so. Eigentlich macht er Gewalt nur viel, viel krasser, er übertreibt einfach massiv. Das sind ja die unrealistischen Tode bei Tarantino. Dieses Spritzen von Blut, dieses, du willst doch nicht bluten, vielleicht ein bisschen. Ja, das habe ich mir auch gedacht, das ist auch so, wenn man so, wir haben gestern gedreht, so wie ein Messer durch eine Hand gestochen wird, so und da war halt so das halbe Messer auf die Hand geklebt und da war dann auch viel Blut, wo ich mir auch dachte, wahrscheinlich, wenn du wirklich jemanden, der eine Handfläche vor dir auf dem Tisch legt und du haust ihm in die Hand, da wird wahrscheinlich im ersten Moment überhaupt kein Blut rauskommen, halt danach so, weil da ist ja auch der Blutdruck, in so einer Hand ist da viel Blut drin. Weiss ich doch nicht, wie viel der Blut drin ist. Ganz kurz. Ich hoffe, mich so anzufragen. Ist das mit einem Kreuzverhör oder was? Stell dir jetzt mal ein Wasserglas vor und sag mir, wie viel Zentimeter Blut in einer Hand ist.
Nimm eine Hand und drück die so aus, wie viel Blut ist in der Hand. Ich glaube, hier ist schon so eine Flasche, wie viel ist das? 300 Milliliter. 300 Milliliter, Blut in der Hand. Aber da ist da lauter Knochen und Sehnen und Haut. Ja, aber auch Adern vor allem, viel Adern. Ja, aber die sind doch mega dünn. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Allein hier. Der ganze Körper hat doch neun Liter. Das weiss ich schon nicht. Deine Hand ist zwei Prozent von deinem Körper. Das sagst du mir jetzt hier. Neun Liter nur? Neun Liter? Wie viel Blut ist in der Hand? Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare. Diese ganze, wie viel Wasser bei einem drin ist und so. Ja, unmöglich. Das halte ich auch, aber halte ich nicht aus. Diese Zahl halte ich in meinem Kopf nicht aus. 90 Prozent Wasser oder so ist man doch. Aber was heißt das denn, Wasser? Man sagt auch ja, ja, Salat ist 90 Prozent Wasser. Und man denkt sich so, nee, Salat ist 100 Prozent Salat. Ja, genau. Und was soll das heißen, Wasser? Ja, vielleicht sind da auch diese merkwürdigen H2O-Moleküle drin oder sowas. Aber das ist doch nicht so wie Wasser. Ja genau, das... Du kannst ja nicht das ausdrücken und dann ist da... Hat da mal jemand die Moleküle gezählt eigentlich? Scheiss, ey. Mit einem scheiß Wissen. Hat da mal jemand die Moleküle... Das ist eine gute Frage. Ja, mit diesem Halbwissen verabschieden wir uns für diese Woche. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Vielen Dank, dass du dabei warst. Falls ihr euch gefreut habt auf die Wissen geht auch, nee, Fit geht auch lustig Aktionen. Wir haben schon ein paar Einsendungen von euch bekommen, vielen Dank dafür, aber da muss noch ein bisschen mehr gehen, aber ansonsten hängen wir uns richtig rein. Ja, wir machen das. Wir machen viel dabei wieder groß. Sagen wir mal, in so absehbarer Zeit machen wir das abends mal, machen es vielleicht auf, wie heißt es, Periscope, so, Paypal auch, und dann können wir da schön die Bälle hinterher schmieren.
Und ihr könnt es gucken.
Und mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir es ja irgendwie, dass ihr auch was macht und so.
Geil, wir haben schon gesehen, die erste Hörerin ist heute schon gejoggt.
Unter dem Hashtag Fit kann auch lustig.
Finden wir sehr cool, dass wir euch animieren, mal ein bisschen eure fetten Ärsche hochzukriegen.
Aber es ist gut, den Hashtag zu benutzen. Ja, macht weiter, wir freuen uns.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das Ufo-Head ab.